[Music]
okay so this is my spoiler review of the
new netflix limited
series the queen's gambit based off a
novel
so i saw this show was getting
incredibly high praise
i wanted to check it out for that reason
i was skeptical because it's about chess
chess isn't the most thrilling thing but
i love anya taylor joy i'm a huge fan of
the movie the witch it's one of my
favorite
horror movies of all time and she's one
of the best up and coming actresses
she is going to be a huge star but what
it's actually doing right now it has
about
45 000 ratings on imdb holding at 8.9
total which is unheard of really really
high acclaim meaning not just critics
love it but
audience members love it so when i go
into a show with such high expectations
i know i have to bring them down
just watch it as is like i didn't see
any reviews and just
see it for what it is so of course being
me i'm conflicted
i think this is the prime example of a
show where i get really annoyed with a
lot of fans and critics that
love to claim almost everything is a
masterpiece now
and i think the problem with that is
they realize that
parts of it is a masterpiece whether
it's masterful cinematography
masterful acting maybe masterful themes
which i think
it has all those three in the show
but it doesn't mean everything across
the board is that and i'm coming to that
being the plot of this story and the
decisions and how many episodes and how
they went about
this middle patch of the show i really
get frustrated because
people like to just cling onto one
amazing thing about a show and then say
the whole show's amazing and that's the
same thing too
where you'll see excuses where people go
well it's a love letter to chess or
oh it's a it's a character study that's
great
those are all good things but i want the
full package in anything i'm watching i
want a good plot
i want good acting i want good character
study i want love letters i want all of
it but just having one doesn't mean
that's all it's set out to be it should
be the whole thing and stay entertaining
and i think where the huge
problem with this is this show's so
different and difficult to review
because it's not an episode by episode
really story here it really does play
like i agree with a lot of people saying
like a movie it's one long movie
but i actually really believe this would
work better as a movie and there's a
great movie
inside of to me a decent show and what
i'm talking about is i think you could
take episode
one two and three and you have all the
necessary set up
what we need to know to have a great
finale in episode
seven but this patch here four through
six to me is completely unnecessary and
i think you have what you need in those
episodes to make a great movie or maybe
even a shorter series
and when it comes to my writing issues
with that middle patch between four and
six
i think the stakes really fall off here
and conflict falls off
because it becomes redundant we already
see
and why i love my favorite episode
episode two where she's beating all
these guys at chess and moving up
and getting recognition and then we get
a little story here where
we start to see former opponents of hers
she starts learning from them and starts
beating better and better opponents
however by the time you've hit six hours
of watching this on loop it gets
tiresome because again
in particular i'm just thinking of the
moment where she's at benny's place and
everyone's in the basement she's beating
them in a line
how many times we have to see this we
already know she's a great chess player
we know she's getting better
but it keeps going and going where
there's not really that high of stakes
and i think
a big thing they missed out on is really
zoning in on her drug addiction
to these tranquilizers and to alcohol in
general
where i feel like they forgot about it
and they bring it back in the finale and
that really is frustrating because it's
such a main point
just in the first episode in the first
scene where we know she's gonna go
to this story where she's facing borgov
and she's
hung over so we know she's a drug and
then episode one in her backstory
we learn about her getting tranquilizers
as a kid at this orphanage
but it seems like there's this
gallivanting happening between episodes
four and six especially when she's
traveling with her mom
and they tip into it but it's like she
has an on and off switch with this drug
addiction which is pretty odd and
you almost don't see enough of the
consequences of her erratic behavior you
don't see enough of her erratic behavior
she seems like she's in pretty good
states throughout these matches and
it's kind of succeeding everywhere she
goes i don't think there's enough
of an opposing force here it's just
getting this character to grow
which i'm talking about good character
growth and good character study
two faces or eventual opponent in borgov
and beat
borgoff so it's like this rocky iv meets
annie and i think that's good but
man to have it go over seven episodes
and just not have enough
weight and clashing here because again
you need
two forces especially protagonists to be
unrelenting here for what they want and
she starts out that way
and then she becomes this character she
even has lines like i don't know what i
want and that really goes into her
being it's not she has the part of
unrelentless in her
chess game and determination she's like
the jordan of chess but
in her life she's a weak character in
that sense to me where they didn't go
enough into her head and i think
a criminal mistake they made is they
saved it for a big reveal that
her mother actually was the one who
drove them
in a attempted suicide of her and her
daughter and
i feel like that should have been known
way earlier and would have added much
more understanding of the character and
stakes and really got us more into her
head because i feel like they only
scratched the surface with her
especially with her demons
and there's some things that to me i
really do have a problem with this that
with neville longbottom right
he gets his teeth fixed for her and this
girl is beautiful and she's genius and
she's
someone who loves the game you love
right and you're this
nerdy chess player and you're gonna
leave her because of pills
i do not buy that for a second and you
saw this constantly happen even with
benny where he's like
at first he's like no sex okay yeah that
guy's gonna say that
sure you know it's like you gotta give
me a little more realism here
she is beautiful she is exactly type
she's smart and they're just all
oh man such casanovas that they don't
they wouldn't even want to
dare go near her and then when they do
it's it feels odd it's like they felt
like every character
there had to be sleeping with and that
kind of got annoying to me because i
didn't
again i think it just falls back into
this redundancy of this show but my god
neville longbottom to just
leave her just without even having a
thorough conversation about the pills
i mean this guy's got it good here you
know address it figure it out
i mean jesus christ if this guy in real
life saw her putting a tranquilizer
right into her butt
he wouldn't go anywhere so that just
really
frustrated me and that's the tough thing
about this is it also is in that
category of it is a sports
genre it's like a sports movie i feel
dragged out
and the problem with sports shows are
really hard to pull off for this reason
because
again it's usually not totally high
stakes
in the part of humanity it is in the
sports realm and that holds here with
the chess
but they did not lean enough into really
what they had set up in her
troubles in her life and her psyche i
wanted to go more into her mind now
themes really worked well here i really
in particular liked how they wrapped it
full circle where she looks up
in her chess game against borgov and
doesn't have to depend on the drugs
anymore
and that was really powerful and i think
that whole
message was powerful i also like how it
delved into her being this
genius but the consequences and the
things we all suffer through that people
can relate to that
and being shelled off from other people
and then eventually learning how to work
on a team that worked really well
the themes of feminism here really
worked well but again even the main
love plots just fell flat and of course
she's gonna fall for the tall dark and
handsome guy that's a little more
realistic
but we still didn't get enough weight to
that we got the one seeing the hotel
room with them but
she just eventually says she loves him
so it's like give me
more into that you're touching into all
these guys she's visiting while she's
slowly progressing into a better chess
player okay this is why you're gonna get
bored as an audience member i know i did
but again i still think overall it's
thematically great it's strongest
episode to me is episode 2
and episode 1 and the finale there's
great acting here all around
no one misses a beat cinematography is
special here
and i think the best thing about the
show is actually the production design
and the costume design here
and the makeup all of it really put you
in that time
and you felt it and you got to give
props to the effort of the research here
put into making sure they were accurate
on chess
from what i hear from pro chess players
that they say this
is extremely accurate betrayal but
unfortunately
i think they got a little too worried
about that where they forgot about
keeping an entertaining tv show at
points for people to kind of more relate
and understand with a lot of heavy
chest jargon and i think the strongest
stuff too is her relationship
with the janitor played by bill camp and
they kind of
forgot about that too after episode one
and then came back in the finale that's
my problem
is that they built some really
interesting stuff left it alone
and then came back way too late to me
and they just did not touch
enough on the human part of her
so it's not a masterpiece it has parts
that are masterful
in cinematography production design
acting makeups and i think thematically
i'll give it that too
but its weakness is its script at the
end of the day and how it was plotted
out and this middle patch here was
almost borderline unwatchable to me so i
think this is going to go under the
little pretentious little overrated
category but still
a good watch i'm going to give it a 7.9
i think it will eventually come down and
score to the masses because
people who first watch it are the ones
who were excited about it
and now people are going to come on by
word of mouth and hearing how high it is
so
they might get a little disappointed
like i did who knows but i'd love to
hear you guys thoughts in it let's be
civil about it i know i'm
kind of giving some polarizing thoughts
in it but let me know what you liked
about
what you disagree with me about what you
agree with me about i love to hear all
your thoughts i read every comment try
to respond as many as i can
please make sure to subscribe to my
channel is one of my reviews
i do a bunch of tv shows movies and i
also do celebrity interviews as well and
if you like what i do here i ask for a
kind monthly donation of two dollars a
month there's a paypal link down below
that will really really help me be able
to do this full-time and give you guys
more videos and please follow me
at stevarly's show on twitter and
instagram for more of me and i'll see
you next time